So once we have determined the class to use and the type of constraint,
we can actually express the constraint in OCL and here's what it slooks,
looks like. What I've put in bold are key words that belong to the language and
the parts in plain text, not bolded text correspond to the particular.
Particulars of the UML diagram so we have the context is book.
We have the keyword invariant and then we have a conditional expression.
Recall from the statement of the requirement that there were two situations, one
for books in general and the other is for bestsellers. So it makes sense that we
have some kind of conditional going on there. This is a conditional expression.
It's not a statement in the sense of a, a programming language.
That is it produces a value rather than a change of state.
Okay? And so if we read through it says, if bestseller and
recall that bestseller was a bullion. Then it is the case that
the check out period, which is an attribute of book, is two weeks. And
otherwise, the check out period is three weeks. So, one of
two possibilities exist, and it depends upon the value of that, that boolean.